at the beginning of the movie nurse
marion and the same nurse from the
original halloween sends her teenage
neighbor jimmy to investigate a break-in
at her house he proceeds to raid her
fridge where we can see a six-pack of
pen pals beer on the shelf this
fictional beer company can be spotted in
many films and tv shows the truman show
donnie darko and the walking dead are a
few examples but what is the reason for
this what is the connection between
these seemingly random ips it goes back
to the specialty print shop the earl
hayes press who produced this beverage
prop as a neutral brand for several
different productions the earl hayes
press is most known for creating fake
news articles for hollywood we see a lot
of this during the opening titles for
halloween h20 20 years later or as i'll
be referring to it for the rest of this
video for my time and your sanity h2o i
know this breaks my usual shtick of
exact pronunciations but i'm gonna call
it h2o because that's just how my brain
interprets it these articles contain
some interesting details to learn about
that plus all the ways that this movie
interacted with the scream franchise who
this lady really is plus many other
easter eggs and secrets stick around to
the end of this video sponsored by ridge
wallet the slim modern wallet that holds
up to 12 cards plus cash in over 30
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it's durable and comes with a
lifetime warranty plus every dollar you
spend on ridge wallet before september
30th enters you to win a brand new
upgraded ford bronco check out the link
in the description and use code cc's
worlds for 10 off
welcome to another episode of things you
missed my name is zack aka cz and i'm
analyzing the entire halloween franchise
here on this channel there are many
different routes you can travel on on
the halloween express currently after
halloween 2 you can choose to continue
on to halloween 4 through 6 or you can
opt for a different reality where
nothing happens for the next 20 years
until halloween h2o in this episode no
surprises i'll be once again aided by
halloween expert jimmy champagne
directed by steve miner this film
represents a semi rebirth for the
franchise it was the first halloween
movie to be released in summer and it
takes place in a fictional town called
summer glen the first return to the
golden state since halloween 3. the
title h20 resembles h2o the chemical
compound for water despite that there's
no pools no beaches and we don't even
get to see michael myers cutting up any
girls in bikinis instead it takes place
in a boarding school where lori strode
lives a secret life as a headmistress
under a false name this is the third
alias she's used lori strode lori meyers
and now carrie tate all to evade her
murderous brother whose name precedes
him so go ahead grab some sunscreen and
a towel and let's dive into the things
you missed
[Music]
the opening song is mr sandman by the
kordettes the same song used in
halloween 2 where it tied into themes
about dreams and the unconscious mind in
this case it's more of a callback but
maybe also a slight reminder that
halloween 2 is still canon while 4
through 6 are not we actually hear the
song again later in lori's car and we
see her react to it and turn it off it's
almost like she's reacting to her
painful memories of halloween too which
wouldn't make any sense because the song
was never used diegetically meaning that
we the audience could hear it but the
characters did not so i don't know maybe
laurie is just not a cordette's fan the
part where lori gets startled by the
little girl in the clown costume is much
more understandable because it's well
known that michael wore a clown costume
for his first attack back to the opening
we see that nurse marion is still a
smoker and she too has taken on a new
last name whittington it's not clear if
this is also for protection or if she
just married at some point after
realizing that her home has been invaded
she goes to her neighbors for help and
they have a halloween decoration of one
of the xenobites from the hellraiser
franchise it's butterball the one that
looks like the gritty live-action
version of patrick starr from spongebob
if he were in a matrix movie hellraiser
from the third movie onward was produced
and distributed by dimension films who
also did the 90s and 2000s halloween
films you may remember the pinhead
pumpkin i pointed out in the last movie
halloween the curse of michael myers
dude if they ever remake this movie
instead of butterball they should
definitely use harvey weinstein there's
another horror icon referenced moments
later when we see this kid dressed up as
jason from friday the 13th h2o director
steve miner also did the second and
third friday the 13th films also the
detective in h2o is named fitzsimmons
the same name as the police chief from
friday the 13th part 3. the address of
marion's house is also a reference to
one of steve miner's films yeah it's um
4946 cypress pond the 4946 comes from
the real location where the scene was
shot 4946 melrose hill street and
cypress pond is an address referenced in
steve miner's 1992 film forever young
which also stars jamie lee curtis susan
finley's address is 14 cypress pond road
miner also has an uncredited cameo as
this very apologetic school official who
tells molly about her financial aid
to be situation
i'm very sorry i wish i could help but
he promised him
brutal one of the teams that helps
marian is wearing a hockey jersey with
an l and a number 17 on it the name lori
starts with an l and she was 17 during
the original halloween not sure if
that's what they were going for there
either way he's about to take a big l
from our boy michael myers his name is
allegray a french word for happy joyful
and cheerful all of which he is until he
dies it turns out michael ransacked
marion's office there are papers
everywhere and the file on lori strode
has been empty this scene is actually
parallel to halloween 4 when michael
goes through jaime's photo box and finds
out she's related to lori strode marion
tries to turn on the lights but quickly
realizes the power has been cut which is
another thing that michael does in
halloween 4. marion also has a picture
of loomis when we see him the music
that's played resembles the music from
the original film the picture is also an
homage to donald pleasance who
unfortunately died shortly after the
filming of halloween six the curse of
michael myers one by one michael takes
out everyone involved starting with the
teenage neighbors one of them takes a
skate to the head while watching plan
nine from outer space which seems to be
an intentional callback to the original
halloween when lori and tommy are
watching the thing from another world
both of these movies are sci-fi films
from the 50s there's also this license
plate ita 1959 the same year that plan 9
from outer space came out coincidence i
think probably and once again michael's
attack on nurse marion results in him
stealing a car grand theft auto
haddonfield during the opening credits
we see marion's collection of michael
meyer's memorabilia which she inherited
from dr loomis we see articles from
after his initial attack on his older
sister in 63 and this one dated the day
after the main events of halloween 1978.
before he goes into speculations about
if michael is still alive there are
photos of people that we've never seen
before which seems to suggest that
loomis or marion suspected michael of
having other victims during the 20-year
gap there are a couple of mistakes in
these articles like this one that says
laurie strode sole survivor of october
mass murders this forgets about loomis
tommy lindsay and jimmy all of whom
survive not me jimmy the movie jimmy but
not the h2o jimmy the old jimmy there
are just too many jimmies this article
incorrectly states that the halloween
murders occurred in 1968. it was
actually 78. then there's this one
authorities have no explanation for the
disappearance of the headstone of judith
myers from memorial cemetery no
explanation huh you don't think maybe it
was i don't know judith's brother the
same guy responsible for killing all
those teenagers one of whom was arranged
under that very tombstone at the crime
scene that same day not the most
excellence deductive skills from
haddenfield's pd i went through the
movie shot by shot to see what
additional lore these articles contain
what i found was the truth behind how
michael escaped all of those years ago
but also a lot of other weird stuff
[Music]
if you watch things you miss regularly
there are a lot of details in newspapers
that come up on the show oftentimes we
see a headline but the content of the
article is totally unrelated because
when you're watching the movie in real
time you don't have time to read the
whole article this one from november
1963 starts as a legit story about
michael myers then changes topics
mid-sentence he is currently undergoing
tests for a number of disorders the boy
has no history of violence with the
advent of modern medical imaging third
term fetuses have been observed doing
complicated dance movements i sometimes
find it frustrating when the filmmakers
can't be bothered to just write a fake
in-universe article but in this case he
was so close to filling up the required
space that the article takes up that
it's making me think that the prop
designers actually do this weird stuff
on purpose or as like an inside joke or
trivia item this other article tells the
story of how michael actually escaped
the sanitarium all those years ago by
climbing out a second story window and
descending on a handmade rope consisting
of stolen bed sheets like something out
of a cartoon i don't really know what
the point of all that is considering
that michael is invincible and can
pretty quickly recover from any fall
damage as we see again towards the end
of h2o when lori knocks him off the
balcony as a callback to the original
and he survives both times they didn't
even have to come up with something new
to explain how he escaped it's spelled
out in the first movie when marion and
loomis show up michael lets the inmates
out and escapes in the chaos we
literally see them walking around and
now that you mention it yeah you're 100
right once again this article is 90
legit until they randomly start talking
about michael doing these complicated
dance movements i guess they call him
the boogeyman because he knows how to
boogie at least they know how to spell
his name correctly that way unlike this
article which spells it like the soap
brand just when i thought i'd finally
found a decent article about death row
inmates the story randomly starts
talking about third term fetuses doing
complicated dance movements it's gotta
be some kind of inside joke one
interesting detail in terms of the lore
is that the article states that lori
died in an auto accident not only is
this how lori's parents died it's also
how she died in the halloween 4-6
timeline so that leads me to believe
that this is a holdover from an earlier
revision of the halloween h2o script see
the movie was originally planned to be a
sequel to halloween 6 before the idea of
a new timeline was decided on if you're
looking really close you can see the
stained scissors from halloween 4 but
obviously that movie didn't happen in
this movie's timeline so we're just
going to go ahead and assume that there
were a pair of scissors used in the
20-year gap where loomis was hunting
down michael or it could be an
intentional easter egg to halloween 4. i
just don't want to give them that much
credit after the opening credits we see
a long pov shot a callback to the way
the original halloween began you can
also see white sheets blowing in the
breeze white sheets are a psychosexual
motif that i talked about in the
original halloween i pointed out how
they come back in nearly every halloween
movie since this all turns out to be a
part of lori's nightmare and it does a
nice job of setting up the horror well
before she sees this hauntingly familiar
image when michael is actually coming
after them towards the end of the movie
lori is now an english teacher which is
fitting after we saw her excel in her
high school english class back in the
original there's a reimagining of that
scene where her son's girlfriend molly
is sitting in the back corner and sees
michael out the window the same thing
that happened to lori when she sat in
that spot two decades prior when laurie
calls on molly to answer her question
about frankenstein molly talks about how
victor frankenstein should have
confronted his monster sooner to prevent
elizabeth's death i mean the monster saw
to that by killing off everybody that he
loved victor finally had to face it it
was about redemption
it was his fate if you recall during
that halloween afternoon in 1978 lori's
curriculum talks about the idea of fate
in the class that she's in in the
original fate is described as an
immovable force in other words michael
was an immovable force of nature that
would come to lorry and there was
nothing at all she could do to stop it
all she could really do is run and hide
but in h2o fate is still portrayed as an
inevitable confrontation but molly
suggests that the character victor
frankenstein has to face his fate in
order to redeem himself which you know
is exactly what we see lori do in the
most critical part of the story this
version of lori has been running and
hiding every step of the way even when
she has to confront michael myers in the
first movie it's usually done in
self-defense there's even a banner in
her classroom that says learn from the
past live in the present plan for the
future but she doesn't follow that
advice herself it's very clear that
she's stuck in the past she spends her
whole life in fear of her brother's
return and there comes a point where she
has the kids in the car with an
opportunity to run away once again but
she remembers her own teachings in
english class and instead of fleeing she
goes back to kill her monster this
character arc is three movies in the
making for her but before we get there
let's talk about life at hillcrest
academy actually with that fancy font it
almost looks more like killcrest academy
where do i enroll so are you studying to
be a killer or a final boy no comments
lori is very overprotective of her
teenage son and as a side effect kind of
prevents him from living his life as
this unfolds we see her grab a box of a
life cereal and put it away for
safekeeping this feels somehow symbolic
even john's friends make fun of him for
it 20 years from now you're still going
to be living with her probably running
some weird motel out in the middle of
yosemite yep it wouldn't be a things you
missed episode if there wasn't some kind
of reference to alfred hitchcock's 1960
horror classic psycho if you somehow
haven't seen it it's about a character
named norman bates who at one point
lives with his mother norma bates and
they run the appropriately titled family
business the bates motel jamie lee
curtis who plays laurie is the daughter
of janet lee who stars in psycho and she
also makes a cameo in h2o where her name
is normal well good morning good morning
norma is the one to deliver this line
well hey it's halloween i guess everyone
is entitled to one good scare which is
the same iconic line that sheriff
brackett has in the original and later
on in halloween kills during that
conversation norma senses lori's
distress and offers some maternal advice
i know it's not my place if i could
be maternal for a moment which is funny
because again that is her actual mother
in real life it's all so corny it kills
me every time i see it as she walks away
we hear a little piece of bernard
herman's musical score from psycho and
she returns to her vehicle which is just
like the one her character drives in
psycho it even has the same license
plate number that was probably enough of
a psycho homage but hey why not just add
one more in there
psycho i also noticed some music by
h2o's composer john ottoman that isn't
from psycho but is very reminiscent of
bernard herrmann's style
unfortunately for ottoman some of the
music was taken out and literally just
straight up replaced with music from
screen the scene where michael chases
them through the corridors uses the
music from the garage scene and screen
and part of the intro with nurse miriam
uses some of the music from the casey
becker intro and screen in fact you
probably realize that h2o's intro itself
is very similar to the intro from screen
both involve a woman who's home alone
and realizes she's being stalked at the
front and back door who then contacts
the police but before they arrive runs
outside to try and escape in fact there
aren't many elements from h2o that just
scream scream from the contemporary
media references to the northern
california setting and there are two
reasons for this one stream came out in
1996 and revitalized the slasher genre
in a way that 1995's curse of michael
myers did not kevin williamson was
heavily involved in writing the script
despite not getting the final on-screen
credit two the original halloween was
heavily featured in scream as the movie
that all the kids watched at stumacher's
halloween party the halloween franchise
would link back to scream by showing
scream 2 as the movie that molly and
sarah have on the tv in their dorm room
scream 2 is also the screen movie that
takes place on campus much like h2o if
you've seen my scream things you missed
you know all about how the intro of
scream has a part where mr becker
discovers their home has been broken
into and tells his wife to go down the
street to mackenzie's house to call the
police get the car
drive down to the mackenzies call the
police this was a reference to the
original halloween where lori tells
tommy and lindsey to go call the police
from the mackenzie so in h2o the
halloween franchise responds by having
lori tell the kids to call the police
from the backers i want you to drive
down the street to the becker's the mile
down the road tell them to call an
ambulance and get the police there was
even a connection between ghostface and
michael myers h2o michael was played by
chris duran who was under the ghostface
mask for parts of scream too as much as
i could go on about the newfound
relationship between halloween and
scream we haven't even begun to talk
about who laurie was talking to on the
phone connections to the original movie
that you might have overlooked and the
rest of the things you missed
the group of students staying back from
hillcrest academy's yosemite field trip
consists of two couples in the original
halloween there are also two teen
couples annie and paul being the first
linda and bob being the second like the
teens from halloween these kids only
have one thing on their minds
food
whole place will be empty you'd have to
run of it could have a roaming orgy i
love the way this man thinks unlike last
time however this time lori is also
getting in on the romantic activities
she's dating the guidance counselor mr
brennan who brings a pumpkin over to her
dwelling on halloween night i thought
we'd do this right history is kind of
repeating itself here in 1978 lori
brought a pumpkin along to her
babysitting job to carve with tommy
there are a number of small moments like
this that serve as homages to halloween
for example after hanging sarah michael
does the same head tilt that he did
after killing bob sims in the original
almost as if he's admiring his work
actually the very idea of hanging sarah
from above like a halloween decoration
calls back to what michael later did
with bob where he was strung up in a
closet this moment where lori and
michael come face to face in the window
harkens back to the brief eye contact
they made 20 years prior when lori
pulled off her brother's mask not long
after she hides the kids in a closet the
same strategy used to hide tommy and
lindsey all of those years ago she even
uses the same lie do as i say now mr
brennan's death involves him being
stabbed and lifted off the ground with a
knife the same fate that we saw before
the nurse from halloween too and after
temporarily knocking out michael laurie
makes the same mistake that she made in
the original by dropping the knife at
the end we see michael get brachiated
out the front windshield as he was in
halloween 4. before the rampage mr
brennan goes to check on all the
students remaining on campus but did
anyone find his word choice kind of
ominous sarah
molly just checking on the hillcrest
remains a little strange considering one
of them would soon become a pile of
human remains and then when john makes
the little map for molly and sends it
down the dumbwaiter it looks innocent
enough but what's this i recognize this
from our purge videos that's an iron
cross john tate is nazi confirmed i also
think i found where they got the title
of this movie from 20 years
20 years
don't you think he would have shown up
by now no obviously not after classes
get out that afternoon we see lori
making a phone call as the buses are
loaded for yosemite and i just realized
that it's a bell south phone the same as
what casey becker uses in screen she's
talking to a woman named mrs chaney mr
cheney can i call you right back the
name cheney is usually eponymous in the
horror genre because of lon chain
probably the most iconic silent movie
actor of all time chaney was known for
his portrayal of an array of monsters
which is most fitting for this halloween
movie where the central theme is so
focused on lori going back to kill her
monster unfortunately mr brennan nearly
shoots an innocent man in the process he
got a little too jumpy when the security
guard ronnie came up to check on that if
we go back and slow down that scene it
is actually michael approaching in that
first shot but when we cut back after
brennan fires the gun it's now ronnie at
first it seems kind of like the movie is
trying to cheat the audience but when
you think back it actually is consistent
with how hallucinations are handled
earlier in the film there are instances
where laurie has visions of michael and
she has to close her eyes for a moment
to realize that it's actually someone
else steve miner made the choice to show
us what the characters think they see
rather than showing us the objective
truth and i think it's a good tactic to
make the audience feel like they're more
in the moment this is also not the first
or last time someone has been mistaken
for the boogeyman ben tramer got killed
for wearing the mask in two r.i.p ben
tramer ted hollister got shot in four
[Music]
spitz was killed by michael myers after
dressing up as him in five
freddie harris nearly got beat down in
resurrection we don't really care about
that one and mr tivoli got angry mobbed
and kills that one was just weird as
much as i love h2o's story and how it
does something different with the
halloween formula it's hard to get past
the fact that michael myers just doesn't
look very scary in it a lot of this goes
back to the mask i could try to talk
about this but i know someone who
studies the michael myers mask like his
life depends on it here's jimmy
champagne this movie is a very similar
problem to halloween 4 where i like the
vast majority of the characters the
kills the setting pretty much everything
about it is cool but there's one glaring
issue holding it back and that is the
mask or in this case masks by our
account halloween h2o uses three real
masks and one cgi monstrosity none of
them are really what i would call good
but some are definitely better than
others either way michael's overall look
in this movie is just a complete mess to
me at least outside of the mask there
are a couple other moments that took
away from the horror i love when lori
walks through the corridor looking for
michael but then we turn back and we
just see him lowering himself down with
one arm i like how they've added a new
move to his repertoire but like where
was he when lori walked by there's not
that much space right here i need to see
this whole maneuver and then when she's
hiding under the tables i don't get why
he can't just bend down and see where
she's hiding i know that wouldn't be a
suspenseful but it just doesn't make
sense that he doesn't think to do this
ultimately this allows lori to stab him
with the california flag which is
probably symbolic of something but i
don't really know and later drive him
off a cliff and chop his head off
finally putting an end to her 20-year
war with michael myers or so we thought
because michael myers cannot die as long
as you have 20 dollars in your pocket
next up on things you missed a
resurrection would soon be upon us
someone kill me even i cannot defend
resurrection remember to subscribe to
sisi's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications i will i suppose see you
in the next one assuming we both
survived
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]